foreign
folks here we are we might be drunk
we're back we gotta we got a we got an
old fave here yeah excited for this
guest today David Cross you I mean
not to nerd out here but like I hate the
word like comedy education but like Mr
show was huge for me though it was like
a huge show for me it like taught me
like it was like cool comedy to me yeah
when I first uh saw Mad TV I had the
same feeling uh the same sense I guess
that's something special was happening
that was a huge we watched some of the
sketches today because you know just to
you know in anticipation of having you
on I was like man these they hold up
they're great man they hold up there you
go it was a different time too you could
you could get crazy back then
yeah well there's definitely stuff on
there that uh somebody will you know
point out every once in a while uh
like TR you know there's that thing that
people say like oh you couldn't do this
today couldn't make it right but there
are truly some there's a whole thing
with um Muhammad
Muhammad yeah you know in a very brief
little thing about called like these
whatever it is like crazy religions or
some kind it's like a goofy uh thank you
very much this is going to remind some
extremists right now that you did this
and get you in trouble you know we're
right now I'll tell you we're on uh 39th
on 251.
well it was all 16th floor uh you come
out of the elevator and you're just
gonna take a quick left and then yeah
Rogan Studios down the hall so start
there but uh it was so cool seeing that
show on HBO because you would you would
wear shorts and as a kid that blew my
mind yeah well that was um it was one of
those things that uh
it it like Bob was a dress-up and a suit
guy yeah and I was not and I I
was I just wanted to wear what I was
comfortable in because you know you have
you have uh a long day and night at the
studio when you're when you're shooting
at the the stage and um
and I just didn't I'm not comfortable in
suits or or and it's La in the snow yeah
right you know and there's no they're
they were the first several years were
just shitty well in the first four were
in a in a uh a bar restaurant saying
that we just sort of oh got for the
first four tapings and there's no AC or
ventilation and uh and it was hot it
sucked yeah I'm gonna wear a suit and
and I was also that kind of
um to an annoying degree uh comic who's
like
anti-authority
yeah
no I would if I feel I would watch it
with friends like you know some of your
friends get it and some of them don't
get it but the ones who didn't get it
I'm like they're [__] dumb yeah you
know that was just a reaction I mean
there was so many weird ones like the
the monsters of megaphone crooning for
whatever reason that one just like hit
me like it's so it's so weird and great
I think that was a uh if I'm if I
remember correctly that was Paula
Tompkins idea I think it was basically
there was the Monsters of Rock Tour and
um
and just the the the it was kind of
about the hype and the the
marketing of it you know and uh and this
is before Coachella and all that stuff
and um
I think that was that was a great
example of like a sketch that was like a
certain kind of uh
idea that you know was a very funny idea
and didn't have a ton of travel to it or
story and then it just became this uh
you know through everybody sitting
around and working out but it was I
believe it was Paul Tompkins idea oh
he's he's hilarious yeah that was that
was a great you must have had a ton of
pushback from from uh like suits on that
show zero really we had one note which
we took over the four years we had one
note and uh and you got to keep in mind
this was uh early mid 90s and HBO wasn't
that established outside of a handful of
things I mean like dream on was a Big
Show and uh uh but they didn't have a
ton they it was
pre-sopranos and obviously Game of
Thrones and and uh uh and sex of the
city and all that kind of stuff so
um
they you know they gave us whatever it
was uh the comedy block with uh Chris
Rock and I think we followed Chris and
uh and it was you know Fridays at
midnight and anything goes and they told
us like
and also we were cheap we've got we've
got to be one that must have been one of
the cheapest shows on TV and uh
um and they just said yeah we want stuff
that you can't have anywhere else yeah
only exists here and you know obviously
pre-streaming and all that stuff and um
which that was still the case yeah we
literally one note wow yeah yeah we do a
Jimmy Fallon spot and it's like cut that
cut that cut that and you're like what
am I doing here yeah yeah
oh yeah uh it was there was um I don't
remember the entirety of the episode or
the the but it was Bob and I looking
back when we come out in the intros and
we're looking back at our upbringing and
then I play my dad in like this like
1920s like raccoon coat and 23 skidoo
thing and Maryland rice Cub is uh you
know my wife but it's so it's my dad and
my so it's me as a little baby and
um
and my dad in there quotes me whatever
is going giving a lot of attention to
the baby this little baby you know a
plastic baby clearly a plastic baby and
uh Mary Lynn's like you know what about
me what about me I'm like but look at
this cute little thing look at this
adorable little baby and she goes [__]
the baby and throws it down on the
ground and there the soul note was uh
you can't say [__] the baby nah you can
throw it you can throw it and you can
say screw this or whatever it ended up
being who or who cares about the better
forget this baby that was the one note
that was so weird about comedy and notes
you know you can be like I'm gonna kill
myself but then if you're like so uh gay
people huh they're loud they're like ooh
the gay loud yeah well that was a joke
they're killing themselves is probably
true wait wait are gay people loud well
I just threw out something I don't I'm
sure there are some loud gays out there
loud some but is that a is that a
stereotype I just made one up because I
was trying not to get in trouble you
know but it didn't work they're uh the
comments are Furious
um yeah man that's what I love about
those sketches though is like I just
never knew where they were going y'all I
just never I mean we watched we all were
watching The Ron uh the Ronnie dob
sketching here yesterday and just the
fact that it goes to a guy who keeps
getting arrested and then the turn is
that he can't get arrested anymore yeah
that that was that was a real uh
important part of the of the kind of the
you know we didn't have rules but uh we
had a handful of things that we were
pretty uh uh that were important like
not not doing specific parodies of
specific people and to keep it you know
somewhat vague and to be about the idea
of that kind of what that person
represents which I think is in part why
it still holds up you know but um I
suppose I like when you watch snls from
you know there's a sketch about Tanya
Harding you know like what oh I vaguely
remember that you know but um uh
that one of the things was to have to
tell a story with the sketch if you
could you know I mean why not and then
it became a movie
and that became a movie that nobody saw
I saw it okay well
that there's uh I don't know how many
people got Mandy Patinkin in that movie
I did have Mandy patanken we had uh we
had a lot of oh man there was some good
stuff and unfortunately it was uh you
know Bob and I uh you know didn't
officially disown it but we were very
disappointed we were kind of not kind of
why am I even qualifying it we were
kicked out of editing and we didn't have
uh we were lied to about certain
elements of that we wanted to uh hand in
that we thought we we just assumed that
was we would do what made the show
successful but that was taken away from
us uh by people who clearly know better
and uh
and
so it's it's hard for Bob and I to watch
I can't even I I doubt we
either of us have seen it in 20 years
but um over 20 years probably but either
is the public yeah
um that's just as God is intended but
that would never get made today not
because it's offensive just because it's
not marveling because we're too old well
there you go nobody wants to see me
running around with my shirt off at this
point Thank you pretty good then you
were thin yeah then sure yeah you know
there's only so many loud gays that are
gonna watch
but we have a title for this episode oh
yeah loud games
um yeah man that but you talk about like
SNL you know doing those you know I
guess Time Capsule type sketches and Mad
TV will you resentful of those shows we
was party like [__] these shows no not
uh I mean Bob was more because he had
worked there and he did not have a great
experience there
um they didn't get they'd miss out on a
lot of talent like Bob is a great
example of a guy that they didn't
clearly didn't understand you know it's
I've always said this like it's
it's not it it works for what it is and
it's a really hard thing to have
um
to to have one week to turn around a
live show and to and to have to uh humor
uh a guest who doesn't have any
particularly you know any skill set and
comedy or anything like that and that's
that's a hard thing to do
and they I just have zero interest in it
I don't watch it out of like resentment
I don't watch it because it's not very
good and you could tell that there's a
lot of great ideas there and if they had
the time yep and if they and there's the
the the on-screen Talent is is you know
phenomenal and I'm I know that there's
good writing in there but they just
don't have the time uh but that's not
what they do that's not what they're
part of the fun is how quick it has to
be flipped over well fun is relative I
guess but uh you know it's it's just not
that's not for me or people like me it's
for the people who watch it and then
there's a lot of people who loud gay
people I think it's for loud gay people
and that's not me anymore it's the
therapy that's more broad but you go to
Bob at SNL I mean like Tim Robinson
that's another example right he's yeah
his sketch show is hilarious but was he
SNL he's an SNL guy oh there's so many
examples guys there's so many examples
uh but that's not the machine they
create they created a a lucrative
machine and that machine works a certain
way and I have zero interest in that as
a comedy writer performer that doesn't
interest me at all but um
but I mean it works yeah you know still
on they always live weird like SNL is
dead they do that every 10 years about
but it's still here but you can see I
mean you'll see a sketch that you know
if it was if that sketch was able to go
through kind of the process we had at Mr
show like oh man I bet that would have
been a great that would ended up being a
great sketch you certainly have the the
comedic uh acting chops there
everybody's really exceptional and uh
um it's just the writing doesn't get a
chance it's but it's not meant it's
that's not what they do yeah what's your
what's your favorite Mr show sketch that
you ever did oh man uh I you know
they're I mean there's so many there are
some that have a really great memory
attached to it was really fun to perform
you know
or shoot it um some that were fun to
write I think there are a handful of
like Kind of Perfect sketches
um
I think the uh my favorite
and I'm biased because I wrote it but my
favorite one that is just has everything
is the prenatal pageants uh where the
the uh prenatal lit up uh baby they have
uh uh it's it's you know the southern
kind of three year olds and
five-year-olds uh pageantry stuff and
and the acting in it is great Bob is
tremendous the idea is fully realize
there's a lot of funny stuff in there
and poignancy which I think uh
are we supposed to watch this wow I
can't remember this one but aren't
people listening to this video too
they're watching it all right we get a
lot of video uh we'd have to watch the
whole thing but uh that's that that's
the oh I see
Oh that's oh that's the TV show thing
that's not it oh this is this is uh
um you're slipping sound accused it says
prenatal pageant it does say it yes I
think well we had a lot of Transitions
and stuff so you never know what goes
into it and what and who is on your
riding staff any uh any notables well I
mean we had uh Paul that's great uh Paul
F Tompkins Brian poseane Dino
stamatopoulos oh wow Jay Johnston
um uh BJ Porter Scott Ackerman uh we had
various people uh uh throughout the
years that would come and go uh
um
you know Bill Odenkirk uh you know
uh
there's some others no that's that's a
hell of a list
um
no gosh I'm probably forgetting some
is gonna get me in trouble you forget
how long some people have been in this
Biz yeah because did you were you a New
York kind of Lower East Side alternative
guy no no I was I I was in Boston uh and
I
and before they had a term before
alternative was a term but that it was
definitely
especially in Boston in the 80s
um I moved there in 83.
end of 83 beginning of 84 and uh uh
there was definitely like a kind of a
division between two schools of thought
for comedy and then people who had their
uh kind of had a foot in both both uh
you know equally comfortable in each
camp like Marc Maron Louis CK uh those
guys kind of uh did both yeah did both
very well
um uh and then some people who didn't
cross over to the other thing as easily
but Janine Garofalo was a big part of
that but there was no it wasn't like we
all sat down and you know it strategized
it out it just sort of was and then we
had a lot of places to play like there
was catch rising star in Cambridge and
that was definitely the alternative or
quote unquote whatever you want to call
it experimental you know and then there
were you know there was uh uh you know
Knicks and comedy connection and uh in
various places that were way more of the
you know
kind of Blazer yeah brick background and
roll your sleeves up and you know punch
line set up punchline setup punchline
did the same act for literally decades a
lot of those guys yeah yeah yeah yeah
and they're great I mean yeah like you
would some of those guys are
so it I mean just so extremely talented
and and just in awe of them but then
when you see them over the years and you
keep working with them and you're like
you
this is the same literally the same
thing like well I think that's why a lot
of them become alcoholics
oh they were already alcoholics I I
think it's hard to do that sober but if
you're hammered you're like it's like an
autopilot thing you can just kind of go
on but to be totally present for that I
think it is hard but then the option is
don't become an alcoholic and write some
new [__] bits well I'm at the fan I'm
trying to make sense of it yeah I don't
know I mean maybe but there was a big uh
uh you know there was kind of a macho
element to it too it kind of murder uh
to what to murder to kill to kill yeah
and to and to be the top of that food
chain and uh and and I mean like really
talented guys like the funniest [__]
guys but it was it was a little
depressing like you know that they've
been because you know him personally and
you know that this certain thing
happened somebody ended up in jail or
whatever something happened and like
you're not gonna incorporate that into a
bit you can't that's you're still doing
jokes about paper towels
it's just weird it was weird and and uh
um they're not tapping into the darkness
that and it's gold a lot of those
stories but it would require failing and
working the bit out where they have to
go out there and crush it that I think
is a big part of it yeah I think you
just hit the nail we have to have a lot
of humility to keep writing because yeah
it sucks to bomb yeah I think that's a
big part of it and if you're you know
this this is you know
times were flushed and there was a glut
of uh uh
um places to do comedy everybody wanted
it and you you know if you're one of
those top guys you could make a really a
lot of money doing five sets a night
over the weekend yep all cash onto the
table and tons of blow and drinking and
partying and uh and yeah I mean you
could it was it was a uh it's a
lifestyle that would catch up with you
of course yeah I mean it was it's tough
to say no to that you know yeah but I
think you mark you see you I think the
idea of working material out and not you
know and not killing is just they they
don't do that it's not part of their
thought process I know but it's hard I
got an hour right now that's cooking and
then you throw the new one in and it
just you just fall off a cliff and they
have to get it back up so I get it but
you still got to do the new but then
what David's saying it's also true that
you become that guy whose reputation is
to kill so if you don't kill they're
like what the [__] totally so that's
that's tough too I mean there's nowhere
to really work out they're not gonna go
ahead and open mic or something like
that yeah well if you don't have a
following you start playing gigs where
they're booking you two have the killers
yes yes you know so it's tough It's yeah
it's a it's just a different mindset a
different approach a different uh you
know you value different things
differently you know and yeah
it's one thing cool about Louie is like
when he was doing that a a year an hour
a year thing yeah you know he'd have
this great special we all loved him he
was huge he was you know praised and
then he would come back with nothing and
he would bomb for like three months yeah
absolutely and we were all like this is
the guy and then three months and ten
days and it was murdering yeah it's
that's yeah it's called work yeah yeah
yeah and uh and and that part
can suck but it's also it's also fun and
thrilling you know uh satisfying to
there's a there's like a piece that
you're just about like I don't know I
can't crack this I know there's an idea
there somewhere I've tried it and it's
just not worth the time and and then you
are about to ditch it and you just
stumble across like oh I'll approach it
this way not this way and uh it's great
it's a great feeling and you nail it and
uh and then it becomes you know then
next thing you you're awarded a Nobel
Peace Prize you're at the Kennedy Center
Honors oh all kinds of stuff you get a
Skechers uh you know promotional
contract or a free pair of shoes I'm
going for Vans I'm a Vans man but uh but
nonetheless guys you never see where
I've never seen mullaney try anything
new and and struggle every time I see
him he's just got gold yeah there's some
guys out there and girls who are just uh
you know just on it Kumail was like that
everyone's got a place they bombed like
he must do it like on the road slipping
it in and then just he's probably just
smooth that you have to everyone's got
that yeah yeah yeah because if we're
watching Chris Rock Miss on a couple
then everyone is true you know that's
that's what this is for yeah yeah this
the seller is for that and uh and there
are a couple places don't forget when
you go to uh La you go to The Improv or
there's a handful of places where
and and it's mostly where there's a
tourist crowd and they
don't give a [__] if it's not your a
material they're they're thrilled that
you know Aziz or Sarah Silverman or
whoever is like oh my God we we went to
New York and went to LA we went to
Chicago and and we went to go see a
comedy show and you're never gonna guess
who came down and they don't I don't
think they care that much that it was
you know it wasn't
seven minutes a solid [__] they're just
thrilled that and and who wouldn't be
you should but we're not Sarah Silverman
level you're not yet I mean wait till
the you know the blockers kick in and
you know that loud gaze chunk that
starts hitting no we uh
no oh look there we go yeah oh yeah but
uh have you you've noticed that Mateo
and Mark look they share a similar way
looks are you serious yeah wow that's a
nice thing anyone's ever said to me I
don't see it oh I do maybe if I get a
stash I Mateo and I were making out the
other night really I
he's all Italian I'm half Italian so
maybe there's something there but just
look at that come on guys that looks
like you it looks like you doing a
character
that's his personality by the way yeah
but that'll get me canceled but uh no it
is interesting I mean do you still tour
a lottery on the road a lot I'm about to
uh go out and tour thank you for setting
that up Sam that's beautiful that was
just perfect why you can uh go to uh my
website officialdavidcross.com and
you'll see the dates uh and if there are
tickets available for uh summer sold out
sure I'll say that
um uh for the tour it's called there it
is worst daddy in the world tour and uh
you can go get tickets it starts in
early March and will run the first leg
is up so please don't if you don't see
your city or town I will be going to
more places in Canada and Europe as well
so don't get upset we will be
putting the second leg of dates up
shortly but yeah there's the first leg
that goes from March into uh
June I think a lot of great rooms here
oh yeah good stuff Danforth just did
that one great room which city is it
Toronto Toronto I recorded a CD there oh
wow yeah you use our buddy to open a lot
uh Sean Patton yeah Sean's going out on
on this one oh yeah
he's great great comment um tough follow
I bet I mean he's a high energy fat guy
I I I uh I love him I love his uh his
brain and his uh how quick he is and how
uh extemporaneous it all seems and uh
yeah I I he's great he's one of the
goods yeah would you say one of the good
loud fats one of the good loud fats yeah
great stuff he's uh portly yeah you just
get out of a relationship he looks good
ladies there you go girl very good did
that not yeah yeah no I didn't know that
I did the open relationship which always
works yeah oh no yeah I don't know if we
should be saying all right she's got a
ukulele
[Laughter]
but we love you and we love Caitlyn too
good people yeah uh you you because Sean
likes to booze yeah and I think you like
a nice uh I do adult beverage every now
I met you in a bar you definitely won't
remember this because many years ago but
we were in a year was
1999. no but the bar with the blue one
you were just hanging there he was
having a drink and a show popped up
which like I'm sure if you're a comic
because you're worse than that you're
like I just I'm going to get away from
this one can I take a guess because this
has not happened too often yeah was it
uh Parkside no it was actually but it
was Lower East Side okay it was a
different that is a classic but uh
because that happened to me it hasn't
happened very often but I remember being
at Parkside and I'm there drinking with
some friends and like all right we gotta
are you here for the show we're gonna
we're gonna get ready like oh no no no
no you want to do a set oh no no no no
no no well this night you did do a set
and I thought yeah you were just having
a beer and they were like do you want to
go on you were like yeah right and I was
like damn that's a comic what bar is
this uh it was on first and a I think I
don't remember the name Mars bar I don't
know no second and a maybe second and a
who's that area yeah that would be the
what library doesn't have uh stand up no
I did I did a Parkside launch oh wait
wait was it um
2A upstairs yeah that's what it was yeah
that was it well that was my I used to
live across the street so that was you
know one of three regular regular bars
that I go to
um
and uh so yeah that makes sense there's
always a show there it feels like every
time I walk by I see people sad that
they have to listen to Comedy I did a
show Once at Parkside Lounge it was like
brand new to Comedy and this guy ran a
show there I don't remember his name but
he hosted a show through good comics on
the show he has a full-on racist
meltdown it was like a Michael Richard
thing before Michael Richards he just
starts chanting the n-word he walks the
entire room wait he was a comic where he
was putting the show together
he just goes on a full-on screaming the
n-word chanting it and everyone's like
what the [__] they walked out one by one
so no one was left and then he said he
was going to throw me on
and I'm just sitting there and he walks
over to me he goes yeah it didn't work
and I was like that what you thought
that was gonna work oh that was a bit
yeah he thought that was like
performance he thought he was like doing
some like performance art thing and I
was like yeah I could have you should
have run that by someone I can't believe
he saw Sean Pat
brutal that's crazy that was a lot more
performance already because remember uh
what was that place no no you see Jimmy
I saw Jimmy Fallon there years ago it
was on a and and second or first stay in
first oh face boy had an open mic there
ah that was a famous bar we had an
upstairs there was always celebrities in
there but they they had what they called
the uh first would have been like uh
there was um
it was the library no I know the library
it was across the street from the
library so double down I know that one
that was a it was a couple it was a
couple doors up
oh it was two floors but it had a oh
it's the the Iris Place the the Mario
Malley's or whatever uh they had a
second floor okay it used to be
something it was like Angelica's
Angelique Angela anyway something like
that but yeah yeah there was always
there was a mic there was these guys
called Art Stars that's what they call
themselves and there was all these
performance artists one guy would do
slam poetry one girl would do the yeah
the vagina uh painting with the brush
you know thank you it was the whole
thing and then I'd go up as a
traditional stand-up and they were like
Square dork
because I do a lot of like setup punch
jokes too so if they're not working
you're just kind of like well just
listen guys nobody nobody
is not going to like your stand up if
you have a traditional uh thing nobody
at those places are gonna go hey this
guy just said a setup and then the setup
had something funny at the end of it I
know but that's in our head for example
yeah yeah it's but it's not it's I think
you if you're funny you're funny I I
agree yeah because you know there was a
little more secure now I feel
comfortable in any room but there was a
time when I was like oh I don't do this
room I'm more of a club comic we I mean
that was actually something that we ran
into when uh um when uh this is going a
little bit further back but in Los
Angeles that whole out of the Mr show
that whole crowd
um
you know the and then and when people
started you know when the New York Times
wrote about alternative comedy somebody
came up with that thing and that became
a a thing now there's oh and the Larry
sander show has Janine Garofalo and
Maryland rice cub and Bob Odenkirk and
all that well it suddenly became a thing
and then getting uh either friends of
ours or people that we admired that were
you know more traditional Comics come on
down do the show and this happened a
bunch and people be really nervous they
would they would had that thing in their
head like yeah one of my there's uh it's
like what is it gonna be filled with
punk rockers having a mush pit you know
like that like uh uh that attitude and
it's gonna be fine they don't nobody
yeah [__] just be funny and you're funny
it'll be fine don't worry about it I
know but don't you think that some
people thought your comedy style like
this show was so original and kind of a
Cool vibe that maybe that you look down
on a more traditional style
um perhaps yeah but that but we tried to
dispel that notion immediately you know
that's nice because it wasn't the you
know it happened more than a handful of
times sure like oh I don't know if
they're gonna like me like of course
they'll like you yeah there's no there's
no rule they just be funny and you and
it's a person that you know and admire
so you're you know that there's
something there just come down and
you'll just Discover it just have a it's
a it's a safe place yeah it's a comedy
safe place yes and he had guys who would
I would see Todd Berry at the cellar
then I'd see Todd Berry at UCB and he
would kill everywhere yeah yeah Todd is
uh is hilarious yeah it's a funny guy
what about uh what do you get recognized
from the most because you've done so
much stuff I mean is it Arrested
Development is it mystery no it's uh I
was reporter number three in the Amelia
Earhart story nice
um that's big it is big and uh and like
does she show up at all in the movie
um yeah it's her story oh nice
um and
and uh you know a lot of people go
excuse me uh I'm 92 years old but if I
remember correctly weren't you reporter
number three that's pretty cool and the
Amelia Earhart story I'm gonna go yeah
yeah
um I you know Tobias yeah it's Gotta Be
the main thing uh
uh by far and then uh yeah you get your
random
uh I was at a bar Sam you're gonna love
this because I was at a bar by myself
drinking uh the other night and uh
um
I got a note on a piece of like uh
you know paper bag brown paper bag it
was just torn off at folded yeah I put
it in front of me and then walked back
to his table uh said thank you so much
for Todd Margaret I'm a big fan whoa
and he was a middle-aged uh black man
hey you never know yeah there's another
one in my corner yeah now you you know
we mentioned you like the booze you're
at bars alone and
I heard on a pod you mentioned you did
crack once yeah uh and you said you you
get it yes it was uh it was uh uh really
I want to say it's life-changing but the
the fact that I
stopped was uh that's the app for me did
it just once yeah for a long it was a
long once
it was um
so I was in uh this would have been two
thousand
22. this was in London and it was around
I want to say 2000 and
uh maybe 2006. I didn't know they got
everything yeah
um uh it comes with a free healthcare so
yeah
but uh
and I was uh there's this guy and I've
mentioned this guy and people are like
oh yeah well they know his name or
whatever he's he's dead now but um he
was famous
um I didn't know this at the time I was
in Camden and uh which is kind of an
older you know kind of
sort of the where where hippie meets
Punk uh aesthetic and uh and
um
there's this guy who used to sing and he
was like kind of very uh punkabilly look
and leather jacket and you know grease
back pompadourney you'd be at in the
back of this fish and chips Place uh
very small place and um
and
somebody oh right of course it was one
of the vice guys so it was this guy
named Andy Capper uh who who's got
Amazing Stories and uh um who's
you know I haven't spoken to him in a
long time but we would hang out and he's
that's a guy you're going to get in
trouble with and uh and uh we were there
with this uh a friend of mine who
happened to be over there and him and we
ended up
with this guy and these two like out of
Central casting for
London like I would say they were
probably early for early 40s late 30s
but looked older and just kind of beaten
up but uh uh very cackly women
um
and we ended up
uh
going back to his flat which was like up
some stairs and I remember a fish tank
that uh just had dirty dishes in it was
it was like a fish tank not not with uh
not with fish in it but just like an
empty fish tank it was just filthy
places filthy and um and doing crack
and
going this is and with
like really going I like this not I like
the crack but I I smoked this thing that
made me like the disgusting thing that I
was in uh no it's it wasn't like an
hallucinogenic or you didn't think about
stuff and I didn't think
um it wasn't even like Crystal where
you're like uh my future is bright I
love life this is great I'm gonna walk
around and just enjoy the thing it was
just
it it there's it this until you're
actually inhaling it I'm like this is
awful what am I doing yeah people people
willingly
well how do you even get to that point
it just was it going around yeah yeah we
we we uh well we bought it we knew what
we were doing oh no we knew what we were
doing this guy Andy got us uh to
introduce us to this guy this is what
we're gonna do and this is what we're
gonna do for the next hour but that next
hour turned into uh to Dawn I oh here's
the other important part to this is I
have a show that night I'm doing a long
residency at the Soho theater in SoHo in
London and then and it's important you
know yeah and uh and I had always made a
deal with myself always that that I
still have like if I ever
drink too much get too high you know do
too too many drugs whatever the thing is
that will that prevents me from having
from doing a show and doing the show
like I can do it then I have to quit and
I have to quit quit I like that because
that I can't have that and that's a bad
sign and I have a very strong tolerance
huge resiliency for that kind of [__]
and I'm like if it gets up at it almost
that was the point
because I wanted more yeah it's probably
at this point Sun's up it's probably 7
A.M oh boy I have a show that night uh
there's been no night there's been no
sleep yeah I've had a show I had to show
every night
um and then ended up in Camden and then
at whatever it was yeah 10 o'clock
started to smoke crack and I was still
there and I'm all money like yeah I got
money here you go what is it 50 pounds
here's 50 pound I got 50 pound notes and
and I'm blue I'm happy I love it yeah
I'm in this filthy thing with strangers
that I can I can barely understand are
you guys talking or is it just kind of
silent I don't know maybe yeah I don't
know about well I don't know what it was
but can you describe what crack feels
like because we have some
it was it it wasn't again it wasn't
hallucinogenic it was the closest thing
I can compare it to is kind of like
a little bit of crystal meth where
you're not like totally jacked yeah and
you just everything has a little bit of
a shine to it like everything's like you
know what like if I ever had Crystal or
any kind of like meth or something like
that or like coke coke is like a not as
good uh version of that
it's like Scotch I want to try the
scotch sorry what's paper plane oh
you've never had one cocktail here no
make them a favorite plane this is three
papers but also I want to try the the
Glenmore we have a scotch that our uh
whiskey partner Christopher Hart sent in
called Glenn Morris from the 1970s yeah
so we want to try it uh he sends us all
kinds of cool [__] he sent us a bottle
that was like rectangular that men would
put in their briefcases oh yeah I mean
it's really cool old [__] do you want to
try the scotch uh I'll take a a taste I
just want to try a little bit no
pressure no it's not I'm sorry we didn't
mean to interrupt that okay so what
happened with the show it's an upper
where you know what I don't I don't I'm
just gonna hang in tonight and then you
do a little math you're like you know
what [__] it I'm gonna go out I'm gonna
go have a drink and it just makes I'm I
have a tendency to be anti-social and
just be like nah I'll hang in and then I
would
just go out of course this is a
different person I'm describing I was
single I was in New York I wasn't
married or didn't have a kid or any of
that and uh and I was kind of on top of
the world and yeah you know um and I was
in New York City with money so yeah uh
it was a different circumstance thank
you thank you uh
so it was it was similar to this hey
it's a crack
I uh yeah I mean as long as you don't
get addicted I say give it a shot
because I've always wanted to try heroin
but they say one I'll get you addicted
that is smooth
that's all right
that's pretty good
yeah it's no Bodega cat but it's not bad
as good as our whiskey yeah we sell our
own whisk do you yeah we got our own
Hooch how do you how do you do that how
did that happen uh we just said we
wanted to make whiskey and uh
the distributor hit us up yeah
so you don't truly make it you just no
it was just talking you just got a label
we label it you got a label and you're
selling label okay
excuse me but we got a commercial that
sounded like a bodega cat there what the
hell was that
gleef but yeah all right so that's a
crazy story folks yeah or do it just
once just stop just once and that's the
thing I would have kept doing it it's it
was it really I get it I mean I get why
people
it's terrible it would it would just
destroy people and families sure and
it's the kind of thing that you know
I imagine it's
you know you're you're
if you're in the setting where you're
doing crack and you don't know anybody
and it's dangerous and you should be
suspicious of everybody
but then you take that crack and that
all goes away
and times ten yeah you know and again
it's not like it's not like
oh man this is really cool and
interesting or even like getting high
where you're like oh you know I'm just
chill and relaxed and I'm enjoying this
I'm hearing things in this song that I
didn't hear it's just
I can't it really just feel good it
feels great I I was in a really weird
bleak strain setting that uh you know as
the sun came up had a little bit of like
it's almost like after a one night stand
you know and you're not drunk anymore
yeah yeah oh oh [__] been there but your
friend Andy must have known he was
putting you in a situation that could
have ruined your life right
willingly it wasn't a surprise he didn't
like blindfold me and you know so if
he's willing to do it he probably
doesn't have the you know in the moment
awareness right I would think I was
totally willing to do it yeah like sure
and I'd never done it before and I'm by
Nature I'm a very curious person and
I'll try this thing and I'll I'll eat
anything and I'll try this once and I'm
one of those guys and and I was like
yeah [__] it I'll take it and I had a a
predilection for drugs too and I and my
responsibilities were to nobody but
myself and just like oh I got a show in
22 hours whatever right you know and uh
how was that show
it was fine it was fine
um you mentioned the crack
I probably I would I would imagine yeah
yeah like those 80s hacks and bust they
haven't said anything it's done the same
act but yeah good for you I mean if
you're gonna do correct you know you got
no kids you got no responsibilities
you're in as I said there's another a
long time ago it was a different person
yeah uh I mean if you offered me Crack
right now of course I'd have to think
about it
I'm all out what does it last like two
hours I'd say
I don't know I don't think that much oh
I don't I don't I mean we'd probably
maybe you keep going yeah I probably
bought oh gosh uh
because we had to get it it wasn't the
guy didn't have like a briefcase full of
it it was it was
but this guy was connected and so
I don't remember if somebody went out or
somebody came to the door I just don't
remember
um some are watching the mole people
remember that movie about the guys on
the subway and I was like how could they
live like this it's damp it's rats it's
shooting in a bucket days dark days but
they're all on crack yeah
so you can live anywhere it's like you
said you can't dishes in the fish tank
you know it's like that's a little
reality that's like goggles that's an
unforgettable image I know it's yeah I
remember that quite well it's one of the
few things I remember outside of the the
you know I have a vague overview of it
but one specific thing I remember is oh
there's a fish tank empty fish tank with
dirty dishes that's impressive almost
and also
it was such a small place I
I mean the whatever kitchen there might
have been would have been one of those
tiny uh shitty like a sink and a I don't
know yeah it was pretty bleak but I I'm
I guess that was this
it's kind of similar to
you know when there's
[Music]
uh
the guy whether they're like homeless or
they're just Indigent or whatever on
your the your local guy yeah or woman
who's always hitting you up and over the
years does it and
it's that feeling of like I've got just
enough
and now I don't I got enough money to
get a cheese pizza and this will hold me
and I'm just gonna sit yeah in my
room and then I'll come out when I need
more money for another cheese pizza well
that's the thing about meth is at least
with the meth you'd clean up probably
yes oh and you scrub to the yeah
um what I'm saying is all life is
precious
there you go that's what I want you to
take from this all life is precious all
right well you hear that Whitney Houston
man first Gerard now you what's
happening here
what did you oh he went hard at it oh
really no
another beer absolutely we uh we gotta
ask a little bit of reverse the
development I know it's a change of
Gears here but like you know Dairy
comedies so I mean such an insane cast
to be a part of I mean yeah I mean that
was that was uh so quickly uh there are
a handful of shows where you're like the
cast is perfect yeah like I can't
imagine thank you so much I can't
imagine
you know uh uh
other people in those roles right uh and
Ron Howard directing
are narrating yeah narrating sorry um uh
it just yeah it was uh
an amazing cast that that kind of got
pulled from every every corner and you
think about you know nobody really knew
who uh Michael Sarah always saw cat were
and and only you know I was I was you
know uh
under the radar and nobody knew who will
was and
um or Tony Hale oh yeah I mean this just
it was pretty amazing just all
heavyweight it's like everyone on that
and I mean rip Jessica Walter man she
was so damn fine were you oh yeah were
you close with her at all instead or no
uh how much not I mean not particularly
close so I mean we were all you know
supportive of each other and uh you know
we worked together for
five years
um over the years and um you know all
that cliche [__] about being a family is
true I mean you really yeah
um but yeah it was uh
I mean I'm still friendly with I was
just hanging out with Michael uh you
know four or five nights ago oh wow yeah
doing crack nice
and Michael just had a kid
um all right yeah yeah that show I mean
it's on Netflix so I just put it on and
it's so fun it's so it might have the
most jokes per minute maybe 30 Rock yeah
it's up there with
uh rapid fire yeah well they were I
remember when it first came out
um
and uh you know the internet was was not
new but relatively we were kind of
finding our way with it but having to I
should say having to but discovering
uh jokes that I didn't realize were
there yeah through like chat rooms and
stuff the things that I didn't get when
we were shooting wow or watching it
later like it didn't occur to me that
yeah you know either conceptually or
right you know was planted in one
episode and then paid off a season later
in another episode [__] like that
there's a documentary about the show and
like people who love the show and it
they have [__] in there they talk to the
writers and half of it I missed on the
show yeah I mean down not just a regular
cash but down to like Carl Weathers is
it I mean yeah it's amazing yeah it's of
a soup yeah
yeah amazing uh and Henry Winkler yeah
oh my God yeah quite a cast
yeah
yeah it doesn't get any funnier than
that
yeah man that's one it's one of those
things I think about like uh because
they were struggling to find you they
asked they when they first brought it to
me they asked me to look at job and I
had no handle on job at all but
then you watch will and you're like oh
of course yeah
who else there's no one else no job you
know and Tony Hale the I mean just all
of it across the board you know are you
are you still consuming comedy as a
comedy guy or are you kind of like ah I
just go out and do my shows and I go
home
um well probably less intensely than I
used to but I mean I still
I'm still hunting for the
the dark cringy British comedies which
are or many
um Peep Show uh yeah uh
and
you know occasionally we'll see
um thank you
uh a name on you know on the the Netflix
algorithm or something uh you know it'll
be uh thank you
um no pressure
uh I'll take a sip all right see how it
is
um and I'll check that person out you
know yeah um or something you know
somebody that the kids are talking about
I'll go and check them out
um
a guy named uh
I don't know if I'm gonna get this right
Sam Morel who uh you know
I I
just I didn't know oh there he is he's
up on the thing yeah yeah
um
but yeah I'm actually watching this uh
show
uh currently I'm almost at the the very
end of the first season and I'm really
digging it uh British show called I hate
Susie
um it's good yeah it's really good and
uh and also just right up my alley it's
you know takes its time it's uh uh
um got some really cringe moments but uh
they're willing to kind of explore
the characters it's good she kind of
gets canceled online yeah yeah that show
is great and it starts off like that I
mean there they the thing just hits the
gas running which is uh there's another
British show I'll watch it you feel it
they did an American version uh but the
British show Shameless oh yeah is great
I mean get check out the British version
but that show
I mean it starts there's no it just boom
the story story's going is it similar to
the Amer I've seen the American
um I haven't seen the American I read
the script for it uh and I remember
being uh
disappointed that it took place in
Chicago which one of the great things
about the British uh show is it's all um
almost all of it at least for the first
couple Seasons
um are just take place in this uh
Council flat in uh in Manchester and
there's a there's a pub you know that
they all go to and there's like a little
uh off license Bodega type place that
they go to but it feels like they're
trapped there and then and I was like
they put it in Chicago and like you can
escape and anyway easily you can get get
on the L train yeah you know whatever
and uh and the American version is kind
of uh dramatic it's more like family
lovey-dovey where this seems more like a
comedy it's uh it's comedy I mean
there's a there's some uh some parts of
poignancy to it but uh but I highly
recommend it that's a show that just I
mean starts and great cast I'm gonna
check these out what are there like
Comfort watches for you on the road that
you just revisit is there stuff that
you're like this is my room I never
watch TV on the road really I go no I I
mean my show I'm doing like two hours
and yeah that's long yeah it's indulgent
and I shouldn't at some point we'll see
how it works out when with when
um
with an opener because usually I go out
and I just do like an hour and
like let's say an hour and a half and
then I'll come out for like an encore
sometimes a second Encore but and I'll
just and by then I'm kind of you know
half in the bag and I'm just shooting
the [__] and loving it you know you know
it's like when you're on stage and you
just kill it we dick around at the end
too but it's usually like give us a
current topic yes whatever so
I think it's it it it's a good thing
that I got an Sean opening it's gonna
make me be a little more tighter how
long do you have him do just 15 you know
um so that's one bit
well I'm kind of similar my bits are
long oh yeah when people are like can
you do five minutes like no yeah I could
do I can do uh 12 seconds or I have
plenty of like little jokey things or I
can do uh you know nine minutes you know
so dude do you get the guy like oh I was
I I want to see Tobias and now you're
talking about politics not so I mean uh
my
2016 tour what or was it 16
whatever the
it was uh it was make America great
again I want to say that was yeah 16.
um uh that one had a bunch of people
like would walk out oh really on the on
the whole tour uh I mean I can count on
one hand the the shows not including
Europe uh that people walked out and and
sometimes angrily sometimes really uh
did not care for her but but was there a
joke that walked them or was it oh just
you know enough with the anti
Trump or Republicans or Catholic bashing
or you know uh whatever it was that they
didn't like I I'm I'm not Mormon but I
don't I'm not going to stand here and
listen to you bad mouth Mormons or
whatever
um and uh
that's usually who's most offended is
people that aren't the thing you're
talking about it's true on behalf yeah
yeah a lot of that I've ever seen on
behalf of another religion that's a new
one yeah but I'm projecting
assuming that but uh
but not so much anymore you know uh
occasionally I just did this little
little kind of mini tour to get ready
for this bigger tour I'm doing in the in
March and um
uh
everything was great like sold out
everything was sold out it was awesome
but there were two there was uh
Washington DC and
Birmingham Alabama I think was the other
one where
and it happens you know friends of
friends are like hey we got tickets to
the guy from just shoot me or do you
ever see Men In Black well that guy you
know whatever the thing was and
that's how they know me and they they
don't even it's not that they know me
and they're excited it's just like
you could tell somebody brought them yes
part of a a night and and you know
people aren't like Furious they're just
like
it would be the same thing if you went
to
you know an evening of uh White
Christian nationalist racist comedy
you'd be like no it's not for me speak
for yourself it would be interesting to
watch that though just to see what the
hell they do you dealt with this when
you opened for JB Smoove remember there
were people that were mad he wasn't Leon
yes a lot of yamakas out there yeah
walking out
no this is nice is it good yeah paper
plane we I feel like we've kind of jump
started the popularity for this we're
getting tagged in this constantly wait
I'm gonna go back so people would go see
JB smooth yeah in the heart of curb and
he would come out to Bob
and it's all these Jewish people going
nuts yeah and then he would talk about
eating [__] for half an hour
thinking I know thinking because I have
no I have zero sympathy for those folks
oh no no no but it's just a we I mean
it's annoying for JB to deal with yeah
but it was a white crowd for sure yeah
yeah he's a really funny guy oh
hilarious yeah I knew him way back in
the day right way before curves I I
can't remember from what like uh but
yeah like La yeah well he has that old
story about how he was driving from St
Louis to another gig on a snowstorm and
he had like eight dollars into his name
and then he got the call like you got
curb and he was like I was about to be
on food stamps and it just saved his
life yeah
he was just like a road dog
yeah he's a nice really nice guy too
good guy I told you I opened for
Caroline's he's murdering I leave to go
get a beer I come back and he's climbing
the diamonds that's how high energy he
was yeah
are there any Comics starting out that
you were like oh [__] this guy's awesome
I gotta kick it up or like when you were
in the 90s or whatever you're like this
is the dude that were peers of mine
peers or people that you just looked up
to
well I mean yeah they're they're uh
like the people that
and we had a you know as as you guys
know that's a it's a very very
um supportive uh
group of people I mean there's you you
don't get this kind of
jealousy that other you find in other
aspects of the Arts you don't find like
backstabbing you don't you know at least
my experience is people are really
supportive of each other and and it's
one of those things that
everyone could kind of relate to an
actor's situation whether it's good or
bad but even if they're not an actor but
with stand-up you everyone has that
thing in the back of their head like
you truly don't know what this is like
unless you do it oh yeah and you do it a
lot and you will have really high highs
and really low lows
and
it's just not that applicable to other
things you do in life and uh
um
and so uh you know
my peers who are who I really looked up
to and I wanted like it meant the world
to me if they liked something or they
gave me constructive criticism but it
was couched and like you know this is
really good but I think you need to do
this I mean people like
you know the people I mentioned before
like you know Louie and Janine and uh uh
like great joke writers like Laura
kaitlinger uh I mean just great joke
writers and Sarah Silverman and
um David tell and uh
um you know that whole
that whole group of people uh and we
were all friends too you know and then
and then coming out and the people I
looked up to uh
uh like when I was a kid it was you know
Richard Pryor and uh and
uh Steve Martin and then later uh
Stephen Wright and uh Bill Hicks and um
you know people I got to meet yeah uh
which was a thrill and
you know uh Gallagher too
not not the not his brother I was
waiting for one yeah well that's the
cool thing about comedy is like I could
see you opening for a Bill Hicks and
he'd be like this guy's weird or this
guy's a little off the wall but the cool
thing my comedy is if if it's good
you'll get a show you know like you can
be seen as as off the wall by one guy
and then a another person can be like
this guy's brilliant
you know like you still made it yeah
there was there was this uh uh this is
quite tracking with what you were saying
but but but there but it's
similar in that when I was younger and I
was taking whatever work I could get you
know when I was um you know still in
Atlanta
um which is where I started
um
it was a punch line the club there at
the time uh yeah punchline in uh and
Sandy Springs
um and that there is still a punchline
but it's moved I think it's enough
connected to a diner yeah
milkshake machine you see the jello in
the little thing and the glass
but there was a um
uh [__] what was I gonna say uh I lost
my start starting in Atlanta
starting out you take all the work you
can get uh oh yeah whenever when I go
out and I would do uh uh you know it was
opening I wasn't even middling I was
just opening for for various people it's
some I connected with immediately some I
did not
um but whenever if I didn't hadn't seen
the the headliners act yet and I came
off stage and then they would say like
man you got some balls kid uh I knew
they were gonna suck and that that's
almost 100 of the time I was uh a good
Arbiter of like what their act was going
to be and they can't believe Cosby said
that boy I'll tell you you got some guts
kid or you get one of these uh yeah
exactly yeah yeah
that is but do you remember opening for
anyone that you like were like oh that's
a [__] killer like in Atlanta
uh someone that like give you a kick in
the butt like oh this is what it's like
to be a headliner because that was a a
room that punch line that old one not my
gosh no uh not really and that's just
luck that's just you know there were so
many so many people coming through and
there were two main clubs there there
was a punchline in The Comedy Spot which
isn't there anymore
um
and
yeah I never I didn't have the the luck
of but we don't we'd also go we'd go
when it when we weren't working and sit
and yeah try to get half-price drinks or
whatever and sit at the bar just watch
Comedy
um
uh
but nobody that kind of kicked my ass
like that in Boston yes when I got up to
Boston there were there were many people
were you seeing Steven Wright when you
just got there I never saw him do stand
up no I I he's actually
in the in somewhat he was responsible
for his manager so
uh Lauren dabrowski who unfortunately
isn't with us anymore who uh was part of
my sketch group she was a stand-up uh
again but a a foot in both uh worlds
um I had this sketch group there and uh
um
and that she went on to be the head
writer for Mad TV eventually but um uh
but she died of cancer unfortunately but
she was
good friends with Steven Wright brought
Steven Wright to see me do stand up
because my stand-up was you know weird
and edgy or whatever but also raw like
really unrefined and
um still finding my voice and figuring
things out and uh and he
convinced his manager to come up from
New York wow and that at that point his
the my manager our manager only had
three clients it was him
uh Tom Kenny and uh Michael O'Donoghue
was also not with us is a was a writer
on SNL the original
um Tom Kenny of SpongeBob yeah and then
so many Mr show sketches yeah and uh
and and he convinced so he came out and
saw me he convinced uh Tim Sarkis to
come up to New York I mean come up to
Boston and then he basically signed me
and that you know put me on this path
that brought me to uh West 39th Street
wow there you go wow Steven Wright man
damn what a guy that's cool why is it
called paper plane
is based on uh
uh Pro vicious salad tricks
[Music]
I'm not sure exactly why he called it
Paper Planes it doesn't really seem to
be a history behind it uh most drink
history is just like you know you know
not living anyway yeah that sounded cool
it probably yeah it probably started out
as one thing and then by the third drink
became a completely different thing so
history is a little suspect we got these
fun facts too about the Glenmore whiskey
the 70s bottle from our uh I love fun
well he said uh there used to be an
agreement stuff he got there used to be
an agreement never to use women to sell
whiskey and Glenmore was the first
whiskey to say [__] that and use women
in sex what was the who was the
agreement I don't know I guess it just
didn't it was nice Scotland
yeah so they say it's uh owned currently
by the same company that makes Pappy so
crappy Van Winkle I hate to [__] on your
story but uh oh we got the paper plane
that uh it was it was someone came up
with it in 2007 and based the name off
the M.I.A song Paper Planes no that's
not get out of here
in two places I got a third one that
it's uh 2001 and it's after 9 11.
seven and then it's too late this is an
old drink he said modeled after an old
drink oh
for sure
[Music]
this is this is my favorite new cocktail
that that you've made us yeah you made
us a lot of good [__] these are some
really fun facts
we lost David officially
it was a good run fun stuff fun fun fun
K those all equal parts and the reason
that prohibition cocktails were always
all equal parts was because of cocktail
recipe books uh were seen as
paraphernalia oh yeah
how do you like that write them down so
they made all their drinks very simple
so it'd be like equal parts
you know going
it makes sense but going by that logic
at some point you're just going like
just throwing [__] in a glass right but
that's how a lot of drinks were made
right well that's why cocktails became
so popular yeah it was because you
didn't have quality alcohol so you
couldn't drink it uh
that's interesting because before the
prohibition when uh whiskey was made
legally in the United States uh
everybody should drink whiskey maybe
with a little water because right very
like well made yeah and then when people
start making their bathroom
s that makes sense
yeah well I tried some whiskey that was
made in a fish tank and it tasted like
plates it was awful uh
but no it's uh it's interesting I mean
this is this in Corpse Survivor number
four I think are my favorite ones I
remember that one yeah
okay so I have to see the I've only had
the first one
um yeah man do you have any pet peeves
any anything just bothering you I do uh
can I take a piss first please
show the man where the urine is
this show is sponsored by better help
when life gets you feeling overwhelmed
working with a therapist can make you
feel more prepared and take on
everything that life throws at you I
think therapy is very important I'm in
it Mark is in it uh better help is the
therapy option that's convenient
flexible affordable and entirely online
you fill out a brief questionnaire get
matched with a licensed therapist and
switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge easy if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
drunk today to get 10 off your first
month that's h e l p that's betterhelp
help help.com drunk
hey folks feel like your best self in
2023 with liquid IV I got about 9 000
bags of this stuff I got to bring it in
here because we're putting the booze
down and just one stick you get five
essential vitamins and two times faster
hydration than water alone my favorite
flavor is the strawberry very good
tastes good Goes Down Easy use it first
thing in the morning before a workout
when you feel run down or after a long
night out or on Long flights
I love it I drink a lot we both do so
might as well put one in you get those
vitamins and nutrients going because uh
Lord knows that poison will take it out
of you
free from gluten dairy and soy it
contains the three electrolytes uh three
times the electrolytes as traditional
sports drinks uses cellular transport
Technologies designed to enhance rapid
absorption of water and other key
ingredients into the bloodstream baby
grab your liquid IV and bulk nationwide
at Costco or you can get 20 off when you
go to liquid iv.com and use code drunk
at checkout that's 20 off anything you
order when you shop better hydration
today using promo code drunk at liquid
IV
dot com tell your Valentine to skip the
chocolate roses and romantic music this
year all you want for Valentine's is
displaced get your own artwork printed
on a one-of-a-kind metal poster that
takes 20 seconds to install wow look at
this bad boy oh my God good poster
really seems to good dribble Lindy oh my
God I love that uh 20 seconds to install
here they have millions of designs
available and officially licensed
designs from Star Wars Netflix calling
Call of Duty and more I mean look at
this this is perfect you get Rodney
sweet behind doing that Lindy yeah love
it
oh he'll tell you you're right you're
all right uh your poster comes with a
magnetic sticker so you can just pop it
on the wall and hang your poster no
power tools no wall damage easily switch
out a new poster in seconds click the
link in our description to see some of
our favorites and get yours ready to
hang a piece of art save 22 if you buy
one or two 33 percent off if you buy
three or more discounts will
automatically be applied to your cart
when you click the link or use code
drunk when you visit displate.com that's
displayed.com code drunk or click the
link in our show notes well yeah Dave do
you have peeves
I do I um uh
one of the they're they're I've a couple
I have many
um please and and the first two are kind
of uh
attendant with each other but uh I I
really despise angry like 0-61 a hit
what a punch
um or just knock with my elbow uh the
people who come out of the Subway and
then stop right there and they get on
their phone to look for where they are
or whatever the people you could be run
up the steps and then they just stop
right yes and it it's infuriating and uh
and that's just that's not a just a New
York thing I've seen that everywhere
where people you come off and they just
stop like oh look at me where am I am I
do I go this way or this way or let me
attack my phone and uh yep that's it's
not just directions I think it's like an
addiction too that they just like they
went up steps and they need to just look
at it whatever it is just like a [__]
move yeah million spots you could stand
kind of similar is uh and they're both
the the idea is like I'm I'm not
thinking about other people yes and it's
the the when you're in
a line it can be small can be long uh at
a place to order something when you get
to the front of that line or whatever
that thing is Deli uh Deli sure coffee
play whatever the thing is and you the
menu is right up there
there's no Mysteries no nothing's hidden
and then there's you know there's a long
line you've been in it right and there's
nine people behind you
and then you get up there like yes uh oh
gosh oh my God oh my goodness um which
one is uh
I think I want
um
yeah I guess I'll get the macchiato no
do I want large or small I don't know
that's [__] like that's crazy you had
all [__] day to figure it out
huge peep of mine too and it's this is a
bigger peeve it's not a long line but
it's a line of one person who takes
forever yeah it's a long line at least
if that's what I mean like yeah it's
just the one person who yeah and and
that one person has been in line and
watched people go up there and it also
speaks to just a general
that person is just not aware of other
people and what they might be dealing
with like and they're probably the first
person to be like hey [__] I'm trying
to do this thing yeah and I hate that
[__] that happened you were just in
Nashville we went to Hattie B's last
time we were there and I was like I want
the experience the club said to get it
for us and also Hattie B says you have a
minimum there's not a huge menu yeah
right the hot chicken that's what you're
getting you want a sandwich or a breast
yeah right put one line for a [__]
hour the clubs that they get for is my
no I want to go I want I want to do the
experience win in line for an hour we
get to the front six women in front of
us
they don't order together they all pay
single and on top of it they all were
like hmm
that is we were laughing we weren't even
mad it was so annoying we started
laughing yeah it's infuriating yeah but
you want to just go I know what I want
let me go ahead of you but they they
never do they like the window they like
that moment it's just not considerate of
other people and there's this thing
there's this entitlement of like well I
waited in line for an hour so I'm gonna
take my time yeah as opposed to hey man
this is a long wait I'm gonna make sure
everybody else has you know a slightly
better experience you know that's the
only good thing about the airport are
you gonna go to the airport and they're
like laptop out shoes off Belt Pockets
empty and there's always someone who
gets up there and it's like do I take a
laptop out and that's why they keep
saying it which is annoying but they
have to do it that's a pet peeve
actually is is not not that in itself
but the attitude that the some of the
TSA people have and I you've got clear
and pre-check though uh I've uh
pre-check I don't have clear but that's
enough that's fine yeah yeah
um but uh
the the the thing where they kind of
like are exasperated and roll their eyes
like people take your laptops out like
hey dude none of us here we're not we're
all complying you don't have to give us
this attitude nobody here has gone uh
I'm sorry how does I've never flown
before and the whole thing is mystifying
nobody's doing that we're all first of
all we're all in pre-check or whatever
oh yeah so but decided to like people
listen to me put your like okay yeah we
got it right yeah the later boarding
groups too you don't want to be that's
why you want to be in the early boarding
groups not just to get on the flight but
those are the people that usually know
what the [__] they're doing so when
you're boarding late like you ever miss
a connection you're boarding late these
people are like wait what do I do I'm
like you've never been to plan on a plan
well I think we can get away with uh
let's get rid of the safety thing on the
plane we've all heard it
and no one's listening anyway everyone's
got their earbuds I get really annoyed
when there's a I was watching the Giants
playoffs game and mute the show it was a
[__] good game and they put on they
go guys this is the uh this is the seat
belt and I'm like dude it's [__] we
know it and then the playoffs they make
it long on purpose it's like don't
tamper don't [__] with don't play with
don't smoke
uh petitioning the uh FAA and seeing if
there's a playoff game
all we're all aware
speed it up they always go do you have a
sweet but fill out the survey and I
always write announcements too many
announcements all right you fill that
out every time wow I just write that
that's all I write and I push send then
I send a dick that's like what my mom
says to do she's like you should write a
letter nah I don't think that's
happening anymore well she meant like
long form like yeah oh she really did
right here Delta Airlines
well you've done it again
but yeah that's a good peeve I'm up
there I I saw a guy looking at Tick Tock
in the turnstile like literally like
kind of leaning on it it's four turns
out he had one of them yeah that's
pretty awful I you know what I saw on
the turnstile a guy was ripping his
[__] tooth out I don't know what drug
he was on but he's ripping his tooth out
and this is the yeah meth and uh
everyone on that
he'll give me one last one last hit okay
where's that tooth fairy but everyone
was like what the [__] but not in a
compassionate way they were like dude
blocking the [__] thing right it's
the most New York [__] ever where
they're just like dude all right so I'm
sorry rip it off in the corner what
compassion are you going to show guys
ripping off his tooth poor guy you
ripped your tooth out no and I and I I
don't mean this I know it came off that
way and I I should I should Reese
so but what kind of compassion would you
show him what would you do oh
I don't know what do you think something
do the two two feet away
go sit on the bench and do the tooth
oh something I don't know it was it was
that's a dark thing you see so much dark
[__] in this yeah yeah but you know
it happens it's that it's out there you
can't avoid it but that's what makes the
city the city another Subway peeve is
the guys who try to get off before you
get on or they try to get on before you
get off rather yeah yeah I think people
are better about that though than
I think people are pretty good about
that uh more than my memory of the past
that that seems to be something that's
been instilled in people yeah you still
have it yeah but there's to me there's
way less of that than there used to be
it used to be really kind of every man
for himself and I think there's a little
bit of that kind of
uh General uh
you know Collective Consciousness yeah
it isn't as bad to me as as it used to
be
um since we're doing Subways is like a
huge uptick in people smoking on the
trains now it's insane like when I was a
kid like that would be like an immediate
like cops would jump on you yeah they
would beat you and now it's just a
regular thing it never bothers me I
haven't seen anybody I see it I've seen
people get high and and kind of like you
know try to hide it a little bit I
haven't seen like real blatant stuff
I've seen I saw a girl you know a couple
days ago uh vaping
um which is its own thing yeah that's
everything but
yeah I haven't seen anybody smoking on
that vaping is kind of I don't Vape but
like whenever I'm drunken around
somebody who's got one it's kind of fun
because you're just you take a hit and
you're like banana Walnut it's kind of
fun it kind of feels good Vape apologist
and the whole thing it's disgusting but
when you're wasted it does kind of feel
good I I don't know yeah well it's fun
to suck in and blow out smoke it is it's
fun yeah
I get it totally depends they're trying
to make a living completely depends
you think why do you think you should
like anybody would give you money when
you almost kick them in the face because
it works well the door works there's
enough there's enough tourists who are
delighted by that they they got their
story
I'm happy that you were like getting
some cash but like a tiny tiny space but
there there's some there's some uh
people who are really good and it's
interesting they're very good I don't I
don't care for the I don't care for the
um the phoning it in Mariachi guys I
don't like anybody's phoning it in
um but there's some there have been some
interesting like oh that's cool the
troops the troops are annoying but I
remember the troops the whatever the
dance troops the Army but uh [__] the
troops dude no uh the dance troops when
they come on uh I remember I bombed a
Montreal audition I was like a young
comic and my heart was broken I was like
I want to go it was a year we both
thought we were like we both wanted so
bad and we didn't get it and uh I was on
the train afterwards just like hating
myself I'm like man my joke stunk and
I'm assumed so low and a dance shoot
came on and the dude was just in my face
dancing around me and it broke me and I
started laughing it actually put me in a
good mood oh that's nice because when
you're that low you're just kind of like
yeah you know I saw a baby crying and
the mom couldn't shut the kid up and a
guy dressed as a clown which uh we were
all terrified of but he went up to the
the baby and did like a balloon animal
thing and then the baby loved it and the
mom was like here's 20 bucks thank you
what yeah it was huge I'll tell you
what's crazy that I could never do ever
uh are the guys and and they're not
necessarily that funny but the just the
commitment and the energy and the talent
to go to Washington Square Park put your
uh your little speaker down get your mic
oh yeah and just do stand up balls comic
schools who's the guy was it Charlie
Brown Charlie Baron what was his name
Charlie Barrett yes yeah no not Barrett
well he was like the Eddie Murphy before
Eddie Murphy right yeah Dave Chappelle I
know it was Charlie Baron who was the
guy in Washington Square Park yeah like
80s 90s is it Barrett I think it was I
don't think it was Barrett am I wrong
and he's dead he yeah Chappelle said he
would study him Charlie Barnett Barnett
yes Barnett yeah but like that is balls
I mean that's just a skill I don't have
we gotta be very broad too and you have
to be enthusiastic yeah yeah you do have
to be kind of like
you I mean you're like broad
crowd-pleasery-ish I mean it's like you
gotta hit everybody yeah yeah but he was
uh he's got some clips online and and
you watch her like this guy's funny he
is funny it's almost like the um
freestyling like rap guys yeah go and
and you're like whoa where's that how
are you able to do this like just
you know it's so cool I uh I mean we
talk about Marlon craft a lot because
Matt introduced me to a young rapper and
uh
he has so many so it's a totally
different thing but you hear these
lyrics and I mean they're like jokes I
mean the way they have to like put
together these words and you're so
clever uh the old old stuff a biggie uh
like freestyling like little rap battle
like like impromptu types really and
it's just a skill that's like holy [__]
oh dude that's so witty I mean that [__]
check this out yeah he's probably like
like 17.
he's not even that big yet
[Music]
no I love when the guy caves
that's the best
yeah that's like a talent bed like yeah
I mean there are people taking 20
minutes to do Wordle
I mean it's pretty important but to have
the voice the confidence the beat yeah
yeah the wit I mean you just have to
have everything it's like race car
driver you have to have such low uh
heart rate because you have to keep
thinking of [__] and not get panicked
it's incredible
yeah I mean that's uh it's crazy I've
always always said uh and thank you for
appreciating yourself I've always said
uh freestyle rapping is is you know
really the same thing as like uh you
know race car driving well I'm just
saying you got to be able to uh just
shut down otherwise you're just like oh
my God I need another line what's my
next line and you panic you have to have
it like just be that confident and I I
I'm I'm agreeing with you oh come on
um it's crazy Tupac and Biggie they both
die 25. 25 now well how old were they
it's insanely young how they both died
at a crazy young age
how old was it 24 24. he did a lot
that's insane to have
the body of work he had and died 24. and
the body talk was 25. yeah that's right
yeah holy [__] it's like
that's unreal and Tupac has an insane
catalog he has so many [__] albums
yeah I know and movies it's better than
Jesus cheese man I mean Liz the 27 Club
too they didn't even get that far yeah
what is that Joplin Cobain yeah yeah
Hendrix yeah Hicks no Hicks was 30.
32 or 33.
I think you're right that's like the
Jesus club or something yeah yeah I
don't know uh cancer Winehouse there we
go that one's tragic as [__] they got a
lot done it makes you really feel I
didn't do Conan until I was 29.
and even that doesn't mean much
it was a big deal yeah we have different
comedy classes you know like that Thomas
Conan was a big deal well wait I didn't
do that was my first hang on late night
that was my first late night thing and I
didn't do that until I was 30
uh uh [__] um
yeah but you had a TV show uh
I might have yeah I mean it would have
been because of that but just barely
okay did you ever do stand-up on late
now or there's always panel yeah I did
stand up on and I got in fact we talked
about it because I did
uh uh my very first stand-up set that
wasn't like you know uh evening at The
Improv or one of those terrible I did a
couple of those they were terrible oh
really wow really bad really do you
remember who you were on with
I know John byner was uh there was
comedy on the road I did that twice and
I did evening at The Improv I don't
remember but it was there were
weird and anyway
but I did Conan
that was my first like legit late night
thing pull it up and then uh I don't
know if this is it there's so many panel
we did one panel after I've done I've
done Conan like you know 14 times and uh
and we talked about my
so they cut uh um
a bit that had been cleared and you know
you do it's it's what it will you know
it's like five minutes and 12 seconds is
what you get and they cut a whole bit
that had been cleared and then
I did it was one of the last Conan shows
before he left and uh it was I think it
might have been the one
it was then it was on TBS and was just
him and Andy and you sit around and he
was kind of apologetic about it and uh
and said you know I I any there was some
recrimination there you know like we cut
you we shouldn't have cut you but yeah
uh yeah years and years and years and
years later he he addressed it
um
but it was it was weird because I went
on I started and then there's a very
strange edit that you wouldn't see in TV
you would just never see it where it's
like
um there's a laugh and then it jump cuts
to here going and uh you know another
thing is you know it's just weird it was
clearly covering so yeah but
yeah they cut my one of the first TV
appearance they cut a bit damn that's
crazy to cut it that late if they
approve it yep they approved it they
knew what the set was was it about a
[__] baby baby yeah um and it was
about uh we don't know what Jesus Christ
sounded like and he could have sounded
like an effeminate Southern Man oh
that's why and then I just did Jesus as
an effeminist oh that's great
I turned water into wine yes basically
all right well [__] at least you can
still do it in your act not on TV
well um yeah it's uh it exists somewhere
I think you know but what year was shut
up you [__] baby
because that was big yeah
2001. no it was right after because I
have jokes about 9 11. um yeah you had
been since 2002. the improv troupe right
about nine no salted nuts yeah so
there's there's uh um
uh the thing about Gabriel which is the
name I gave this guy who I saw
rollerblading with a gas mask
um that's all true that is not really
literally yeah I don't I do not lie or
make [__] up and say it's true when I
say it's something's true
it's true and uh
yeah and it was the day after I think
and uh I mean just the whole [__]
city is traumatized it's crazy and you
know there's a the um 14th Street tanks
and uh you know are wow yeah yeah it was
nuts and
on Houston Street
uh so I went out you know the whole day
in the the night was surreal and bizarre
and everybody was dealing with it in
their own their own way and and there
was
uh
uh it was all unknown we didn't know
what was happening what what would
tomorrow bring what's what awfulness is
happening of
um people still couldn't get in touch
with the cell phone towers all kinds of
crazy [__] but nobody no you can look
back on and go yeah it was some crazy
times and the first week was weird but
the mindset kind of like the beginning
of covet you know
all we're hearing is sirens and there's
body bags you know like
you don't know what's happening the next
day and you don't know what you're
waking up to and what kind of world
you're waking up to what kind of New
York City and
and I'm just you know walking around I
don't know what I'm doing uh I guess
just sort of seeing what else is out
there and and this guy uh is coming up
from the west side going west to east uh
on Rollerblades uh a loud gay I would
imagine
um uh sunglasses no sorry not sunglasses
but uh uh gas mask uh and then you know
like threw on his
whatever early Yachts tight yeah you
know rollerblade disco [__] outfit
and he's and he's attitude like real
severe attitude I could see he's coming
up house and there's no traffic
obviously there's no cars nothing and
he's [__] coming up determination
that's New York that gives you hope yeah
but that that was you know a
a bit that became famous from that from
uh shut up you [__] baby that's all
true yeah yeah so you were here 9 11.
yeah I remember uh leaving school and we
had to go to leave school early my dad
came to pick me up he was like yeah
we're under attack I was like
uh Midtown I went to high school in uh
Midtown and then uh my dad we got a pop
quiz that day actually our teacher we
got we got bomb we got attacked not
bombed wait wait wait you your school
continued yeah what are we the Spanish
teacher give us a pop quiz and all of us
were like [__] you we're not taking we
think we we're under attack yeah wait
the wait a [__] second here when was
it was one of the early classes no we
ended up leaving but uh I mean it went
on for a minute we didn't know what
happened yet but then there was also you
know
I don't know if people remember you
probably remember you did we didn't get
cell phone service back then no so yeah
everything was hours I was trying to
call my parents we didn't know I had
friends like no no it was there was no
cell phone service yeah and and then I
remember my family we all like lined up
to donate blood and stuff at hospitals
but they were like we're good literally
every new yorker's done this it was a
pretty crazy moment oh I I yeah I mean I
have similar
memories of that you know uh
and I and I remember when we did uh
because I I did talk to people that
evening because I remember going up to
my roof and I and I apparently had this
real breakdown and and a girl
there was a friend of mine that that you
know wasn't a girlfriend at time used to
be able to still close I said I saved
your message hmm uh you know you let and
I was like sobbing and all this stuff
and I think I just sort of lost it after
a full
day of that stuff and uh
I mean I have all kinds of
not like gonna go into it now but um uh
but the disconnect between I had a
friend who was in Harlem and the
attitude he had
in talking to him and what people were
experiencing
like below 14th Street was just it you
he might as well have been in Alaska
right he's in Harlem he's in the same
bird same island and and just like
asking questions like you know my mom
would ask like uh uh Hey man so what's
going on or uh um you know just general
questions like
uh I can't remember but like uh uh so I
mean do you guys have electricity
and uh um is anybody hurt or you know
it's just weird yeah things like You're
he's literally up
on a you know 125th Street and and it's
just a different world down here it is
uh it's the it was crazy yeah I watched
it from my roof in Chinatown and when
that first Tower collapsed it was the
only time my whole life my knees gave
out I didn't know what that expression
meant before but I literally I fell
really yeah I couldn't control that my
dad worked in Times Square so we saw the
second the second plane hit so he
watched I mean it was I mean that was
like the craziest uh it was the craziest
day I mean I I think about like I mean
thank God you got a like a great joke I
mean that [__] was part of healing like
it's laughing yeah in New York I mean I
think of your bit I think of like Greg
geraldo's bit about the bachelorette
party I think about it I think about the
Wu-Tang song rules like I think about
the Spike Lee movie 25th hour like where
we were like man that scene with Barry
Pepper was like heavy I know when
Giuliani came out on SNL and said we can
be funny again I think I mean little
[__] meant so much I mean I think of
Mike piazza's home run yeah that was
like that was like powerful I mean it
was a crazy time it was oh yeah yeah I
feel bad I was in New Orleans hungover
freshman of college came downstairs of
me and my dad had a weird relationship
when I came he goes we gotta talk and I
go
you know puke in the living room and
he's like the Twin Towers have been uh
hit and I was like oh thank God
holy [__]
and then I went to college or school and
they were it was shut down so I got to
go home so it's kind of nice in
Louisiana
it's nice in Louisiana wow it was you
know it was a break
you know but you know then the news
started coming out you saw the people
jumping you saw the smoke it was wild
you know what another thing I'll never
forget about
September 11th that day it had been a
really uh exceptionally hot well not
anymore but uh back then it was an
exceptionally hot summer and
that day was crystal clear it was the
first cool day for real like the the
temperatures had come down to like 70s
and it was not it was a beautiful day
beautiful
a couple clouds in the sky there's a
nice temperature and
I I remember that very well like because
we had had a particularly hot summer
yeah
and uh we should name this we change it
to flight 93. there we go first joke I
remember hearing uh after 9 11 because
it was like very heavy atmosphere was
Colin Quinn and it was like maybe two or
three days after and he was on the radio
I think it was on Opie and Anthony maybe
and he was like uh yeah people were
saying like something told me not to go
down there that day and he was like yeah
the news
the Colin always Galvin AG is that a
funny one where someone goes where were
you on 911 he goes what year
damn yeah were you were you in with the
with that tough crowd crew or they
seemed very intimidating that Patrice
really I mean I knew them and uh and you
know there was mutual respect but it was
but that was more of a comedy seller
crowd and I was uh you know never really
ensconced in that yeah yeah I remember
seeing you on tough crowd though and it
seemed like I mean you killed on it it
was you know I I don't I the only
thing I remember about that was
uh there were jokes about this will tell
you exactly what it was although I can't
tell you right now but it was when uh
Kobe Bryant was accused of raping the
waitress or somebody in Denver I think
and they were making jokes about
the waitress and I that really bothered
me and uh it and it's like
it was just a you know a thing you know
you you have your own
cutoff points where right that's funny
that's not funny I'll do a joke about
that I'm not gonna do a joke about that
but um and I don't have many I really
there are very few things I won't joke
about but like
uh victims
um like I'm not you know I'm not gonna
there's this is terrible right you know
uh what about a 911 joke [__] tons of
them
um well though that's in the abstract
I'm not I'm not talking about a specific
hey you know that [__] from uh
Goldman Sachs who died [__] that dude
listen to this no I mean this is these
are those are and they're and they're
not jokes about people dying so much
um oh though I I do remember that joke
now I haven't thought about it in 20
plus years all right the thing about you
know the the
New York New York casino and the people
who went to the New York or were at the
New York New York casino during 9 11 in
Las Vegas being like being like I can
relate
that's good I can't remember what the
thing was but that's a funny angle
well hey geez I mean brought it around
full circle with the paper plane 911.
yeah well thank you so much for coming
yeah man we really I'm not I'm not done
oh really listen we still got a little
bit of uh paper plates
station 11 was my favorite show of like
2021. oh yeah that was great that was a
great show really really good yeah I
don't know what platform it was on but
it was amazing it was
HBO right I think so okay or HBO Max was
that about a pandemic yes yes it was
really [__] good man yeah by the way
you've got a computer I don't know what
shows
I'm drunk
oh okay yeah I did not uh like I didn't
know anything about it I gotta watch The
Source material I didn't know I just you
know I did my stuff and that was it and
uh I man it was beautiful and those last
two episodes I was [__] balling yeah
those are the last two episodes and
hamesh Patel
how did he not get the Emmy yeah I mean
he's I mean there's so many good people
in there but he's [__] great now I
he's just great I'm gonna watch it next
this is my next it's really good it's
really good well done it's like a movie
so well to Patrick Sullivan who was a
showrunner who took that book and turned
it it's just beautiful
and it's a it's a surprisingly
optimistic message
and
it's just so well done it's so [__]
good yeah and the last two episodes I
was falling and to watch it during covet
it like really hit home
just all at home is that accurate they
were making it pre-pandemic and then did
they finish it in the pandemic or yeah
we I yeah it was uh uh
I think you know started pre-pandemic
and then the pan
shot in Toronto and I happen to be in
Toronto stuck in Toronto uh my wife was
working there uh it's a long story and
it was it was Bleak man it was really uh
tough time and and quite depressing and
not good for our marriage and uh
and I remember calling my agent Cohen I
will work on anything literally just and
not I'm not uh relegating that to
anything but I'm like just I I'm sitting
in a house that's an Airbnb that's not
my house with a hyper four-year-old my
wife's working and I'm got nothing and
I'm and we're on month four of who knows
how long this shit's gonna be because
you were a lot we were locked down there
was nothing open in Toronto Toronto and
everything was open here right I'm like
talking to Bob he's like yeah man I just
did a set in New York it's great like Oh
and it was really hard really hard and
um we shot a special on rooftops in New
York City yeah there was nothing open we
were just like let's just do some weird
[__] God bless you man yeah we're like
do anything we're going crazy dude I
didn't do a set
for a year and seven months I'd go crazy
I was going crazy a year and seven
that's the longest it's been since I
started when I was 17. I've never gone
not even remotely close to not doing a
set you realize how much we need this
[__] it's so it's such a part of our
just I mean last night they were making
fun of me because I was so tired I was
off the road you know and I was like I
should cancel at the seller tonight and
I couldn't I couldn't do it yeah I was
like I was like I couldn't send the text
like [__] it I'm in yeah I don't know uh
and it's absolutely fine you're along
with most people if you haven't uh saw
my last special I'm from the future but
that is about
uh at least part of it is about uh not
being able to do stand up in the first
set I'll never forget it
um
I was supposed to go so I was supposed
to go out on tour uh and then the the
second wave the Delta omnicrom wave came
and canceled that tour and like [__] it
I'm not going to go through this again
because again you don't know what the
future is when that's happening and I'm
like have to cancel tour which I've
never done in my life and it was one of
the sickest feelings I've ever had just
like I love doing stand-up I need it I
have to do it and
to develop this you know hour and 15
minutes whatever it was and then to have
to cancel it so I just shot it at the
Bell House like you know I scrambled and
put it together and it's on my website
officialdavidcross.com Yes you heard
that correctly and
and it's about a lot of it is about the
you know
not being able to stand up and being
stuck and the pandemic and all that [__]
but the very first set I had was at the
sultan room uh and it was I I came back
with my daughter my wife still had to be
there for shooting the show
the minute we could
and when I say minute I mean what's the
flight
the the earliest I can get out of here
I'm gonna have my daughter for a month
without uh
without my wife it doesn't matter it's
just we're going back we're getting out
of here we're getting the [__] out of
Toronto we're going home things are open
it's nice out my kid can ride her
scooter and socialize and I can do Stan
but whatever and I know my wife's not
gonna be there for months it's like I'll
I'm happy to do it just me and her great
yeah and
my first set was at the sultan room and
I was like just get me anything anything
and I almost started crying wow I would
say I was like start I was starting to
talk and you know going like this is uh
I haven't been able to stand up for the
last time I did a real set was uh and I
started to yeah lose it a little bit
and then I riff this thing that actually
became something in the in the set that
I just kept in there and it was really
fun to do but I just ripped only to save
myself emotionally because I was about
to start crying and it was the beginning
of that yeah you know you can close the
set by crying but don't open a set
and I was like oh this has been a dream
of mine and uh you know oh no no I
dreamed about this day and then I just
turned it into this riff about a weird
dream I had with people in the audience
but it's uh
I
it was one of the most powerful
things I've experienced where like I
it's so important to me such a part of
my makeup and I have to have it
unlike any other I I you know
if I never wrote another thing if I
never acted at another thing if I never
directed or produced okay but if I never
if you said I can't do stand up I would
just it would crush me same same I get
it and that's because that's the thing
that should be on our terms like the
other stuff is like your way okay you
got cash in this right stand up on our
terms so it's so it's so it's a loss of
all control dude that was a big part of
it was you know because there were a
couple
periods where I would say something or
do something and I thought okay I'm
going to be blacklisted or you know this
is pre-cancel culture but uh I'm not
going to get to work I'm going to be
difficult to work with whatever people
aren't going to hire me and I'm always
in the back of my head go okay I can
always do stand-ups right I always will
do stand-up and and Sam you're right it
was a it was not in our control and that
was a real
[__] you know gut punch like oh you
can't I mean I can't even and my wife
was like just go find somewhere to go
like incur in an encouraging way like
yeah go to Alberta for the week and go
just or go to Vancouver whatever and I
got online and everything's closed all
across Canada and there was no going
back and forth because there was a
14-day quarantine because Canada was
locked down damn it was called
stay-at-home orders and um brutal it was
brutal Canada was rough well I mean it
was rough here too I mean
this was opening this was New York was
opening up Vanderbilt Avenue was had the
open streets thing and there's like five
Lanes in the the media and it's like
shut to traffic and all the people are
out there the whole communities bringing
tables out there and they're sharing
food and kids are running around in
their scooters and [__] like that and in
Toronto you're locked down yeah [__]
with way less of the numbers that you
know right right it was I mean I
remember the first set I had back uh I
mean I did the seller and Gotham Comedy
Club the first night and Jerry Seinfeld
wanted he wanted to be the first person
on stage he was like I want to go on
before the host like this is Meaningful
to me he was emotional too you'd see
tears in his eyes I was like holy [__]
Jerry's tearing up this is pretty
historic you know it was like pressing
the New York Post there uh and Jerry
what a coincidence
but Jerry to his credit there was a big
uh plastic barricade between him and the
stage he goes what is this and they were
like well this is to protect you guys
he's like this isn't comedy and they
moved it so there was no barricade ever
at Gotham because Jerry was like what
what the hell yeah 67 people died
it was a bloodbath but Jerry got to feel
alive on stage and that's what matters
comedians in clubs killing guests
damn well thank you guys yeah you were
awesome thanks for doing this see David
Cross uh official davidcross.com uh you
can see his Tour all over the country uh
and Toronto no I'll be in Toronto
Danforth yeah always yeah uh look at all
those dates uh Matt can you read some of
them out loud he actually at uh San
Francisco on the 22nd of March we have
one of my favorites in Texas after that
Houston after that Dallas after that
um April 1st in New Orleans and then St
Louis Chicago Illinois Knoxville
Tennessee wait Chicago Illinois that's
not right it should be Chicago Kentucky
that's a mistake on our end I'll fix
that up uh we got Knoxville and just go
to the site to see more yeah all right
good stuff check out David Cross check
out his old stuff his his new tour go
nuts where you at Sam uh Vancouver
Seattle Portland we had a night in
Portland that should be great Salt Lake
City AC uh Royal Oak Minneapolis added
in Boston uh New Haven Madison Madison
I'm looking at your those are all great
rooms I'm pumped man yeah Miami Orlando
DC Atlanta everything uh Atlanta
Tabernacle oh wow that's big yeah that's
a big deal I'm pumped man yeah uh
samuel.com shows check it out I got all
mine up here Hawaii then uh Spokane then
uh Rochester Miami oh
[Music]
wow I mean the places are fine but to go
from that place to that place like come
back to New York every time in the
middle I never go straight from gig to
Gig it's not necessary if you have to
feed do you have to feed your fish or
what
I like to come back this Tank's only got
plates in it anyway tell my agent will
you geez Hawaii to Maine to Spokane
Tacoma New York Spokane I was like kill
me it's a six hour flight it's a [__]
you gotta connect a lot of times but
yeah come on out markdormancomedy.com
loudgaze we're really doing it thanks
thanks Dave just so you know it's
g-a-z-e yes so don't come you know
jumping up our ass all right you're gays
[Music]
I've had a little much person and
Norman's talking [__] about the [__]
post and I get down in the same way
dangerous
[Music]
I'm out to lunch here in New Orleans
this woman doesn't look like I remember
her and I get down in the same way
[Music]
true